C'est un honneur pour moi d'être ici, et comme l'a dit Chris,
voilà plus de 20 ans que j'ai commencé à travailler en Afrique.
La première fois, c'était à l'aéroport d'Abidjan par une chaude matinée de Côte d'Ivoire.
Je venais de quitter Wall Street, de me faire la coupe de Margaret Mead,
de donner presque tout ce que je possédais,
et je suis arrivée avec l'essentiel --
un peu de poésie, quelques vêtements, et bien sûr une guitare --
parce que j'allais sauver le monde,
et je me suis dit que j'allais simplement commencer par le continent africain.
Mais quelques jours seulement après mon arrivée, un bon nombre de femmes ouest-africaines
m'ont clairement dit que les Africains ne voulaient pas être sauvés,
merci beaucoup, encore moins par moi.
J'étais trop jeune, célibataire, sans enfant,
je ne savais rien de l'Afrique et de plus, mon français était lamentable.
Ce fut donc un moment incroyablement douloureux de ma vie,
et pourtant il m'a donné l'humilité de commencer à écouter.
Je crois que l'échec aussi peut être une formidable motivation,
et je suis partie au Kenya, j'ai travaillé en Ouganda,
et j'ai rencontré un groupe de femmes rwandaises qui m'ont demandé, en 1986,
de venir à Kigali les aider à monter la première institution de microfinance du pays.
Et je l'ai fait, et nous l'avons finalement appelée Duterimbere,
c'est-à-dire "aller de l'avant avec enthousiasme". Et pendant que nous le faisions,
j'ai réalisé qu'il n'y avait pas beaucoup d'entreprises viables
lancées par des femmes, et que je devrais peut-être essayer de faire marcher une affaire.
Donc j'ai commencé à chercher, et j'ai entendu parler d'une boulangerie
tenue par 20 prostituées.
Un peu intriguée, je suis allée rencontrer ce groupe,
et j'ai découvert 20 mères célibataires qui essayaient de survivre.
Et j'ai vraiment commencé à comprendre le pouvoir du langage,
et en quoi les appeler "les gens" nous éloigne d'eux,
et les rapetisse.
J'ai aussi découvert que la boulangerie n'avait rien d'une entreprise,
que c'était en fait une association caritative classique menée par une personne bien intentionnée
qui, essentiellement, dépensait 600 dollars par mois
pour occuper ces 20 femmes à faire un peu d'artisanat et de gâteaux,
qui vivaient avec 50 cents par jour, toujours pauvres.
Alors j'ai fait un marché avec elles. J'ai dit "Bon, on abandonne le côté caritatif,
et on fait marcher ça comme une entreprise et je vais vous aider".
Elles ont accepté avec anxiété, je m'y suis mise avec anxiété, et bien sûr,
les choses sont toujours plus difficiles que prévu.
Tout d'abord, je me suis dit, bon, il nous faut une équipe de vente,
et nous ne sommes clairement pas une équipe à toute épreuve,
alors -- j'ai fait toute la formation
et le meilleur exemple fut quand j'ai défilé littéralement dans les rues
de Nyamirambo, le quartier populaire de Kigali, avec un seau,
et j'ai vendu tous ces petits beignets aux gens,
et je suis revenue, l'air de dire "Vous voyez?"
Et les femmes ont dit "Tu sais, Jacqueline, qui à Nyamirambo refuserait d'acheter
des beignets dans un seau orange à une grande américaine?" Et comme --
(Rires) C'est très vrai.
Alors ensuite, j'y suis allé à l'américaine,
avec des compétitions, en individuel et par équipe. Ça a complètement raté,
mais avec le temps les femmes ont appris à vendre à leur manière.
Et elles ont commencé à être à l'écoute du marché,
et elles sont revenues avec des idées de chips de manioc et de chips de banane
et de pain de sorgho, et avant même de s'en apercevoir,
nous avions emporté tout le marché de Kigali,
et les femmes gagnaient trois à quatre fois la moyenne nationale.
Et avec cet élan de confiance, je me suis dit, bon, il est temps de faire une vraie boulangerie,
alors peignons-là. Et les femmes ont dit "C'est une très bonne idée".
Et j'ai dit "Bon, de quelle couleur voulez-vous la peindre?" Et elles ont dit,
"Choisis, toi". Et j'ai dit "Non, non, j'apprends à écouter --
vous choisissez. C'est votre boulangerie, votre rue, votre pays, pas les miens".
Mais elles ne me répondaient pas.
Une semaine, deux semaines, trois semaines ont passé,
et finalement j'ai dit "Bon, et en bleu?"
Et elles ont dit "Bleu, bleu, on aime le bleu. Allons-y pour du bleu".
Donc je suis allé au magasin, j'ai emmené Gaudence, la plus récalcitrante,
et nous avons rapporté toute la peinture et du tissu pour faire des rideaux,
et le jour de peindre, nous nous sommes toutes réunies à Nyamarimbo,
et l'idée, c'était de la peindre en blanc avec des ornements bleutés,
comme une petite boulangerie française. Mais ça n'était clairement pas aussi satisfaisant
que de peindre un mur bleu comme un ciel matinal.
Donc, bleu, bleu, tout est devenu bleu ;
les murs étaient bleus, les fenêtres étaient bleues,
le trottoir devant a été peint en bleu.
Et Aretha Frankiln criait "R.E.S.P.E.C.T.",
les hanches des femmes se balançaient
et des gamins essayaient de prendre les pinceaux, mais c'était leur jour.
Et à la fin, on s'est mis de l'autre côté de la rue
et on a regardé ce qu'on avait fait, et j'ai dit "C'est superbe",
et les femmes ont dit "c'est vrai".
Et j'ai dit "Et je trouve que la couleur est parfaite",
et elles ont toutes acquiescé, à part Gaudence,
et j'ai dit "Quoi?"
Et elle a dit "Rien", et j'ai dit "Quoi?"
Et elle a dit "Bon, c'est joli, mais tu sais, notre couleur en fait c'est le vert". Et --
(Rires)
Et j'ai appris qu'écouter ne demandait pas seulement de la patience,
mais qu'en ayant vécu toute sa vie en dépendant de la charité,
c'est très difficile de dire ce qu'on pense.
Et principalement parce que les gens ne vous le demandent jamais vraiment,
et quand ils le font, vous ne croyez pas vraiment qu'ils veulent savoir la vérité.
Et j'ai donc compris qu'écouter ne demandait pas seulement d'attendre,
mais aussi d'apprendre à poser les bonnes questions.
J'ai donc vécu à Kigali environ deux ans et demi, à faire ces deux choses,
et ce fut une période extraordinaire de ma vie.
Et ça m'a appris trois leçons
qui sont je pense très importantes pour nous aujourd'hui,
et surtout dans un travail comme le mien.
La première, c'est que la dignité est plus importante pour l'esprit humain que la richesse.
Comme l'a dit Eleni, quand les gens accroissent leur revenu, ils accroissent leur choix,
et c'est fondamental pour la dignité.
Mais les êtres humains veulent aussi se voir les uns les autres,
et être entendus les uns des autres, et nous ne devrions pas l'oublier.
La deuxième est que la charité et l'aide traditionnelles
ne résoudront jamais les problèmes de pauvreté.
Je pense qu'Andrew a plutôt bien traité ça, donc j'en viens au troisième point,
qui est que les marchés seuls, non plus,
ne résoudront pas les problèmes de pauvreté.
Oui, nous avons mené ça comme une entreprise,
mais il fallait bien que quelqu'un paie le soutien philanthropique
qui est venu pendant la formation et l'aide à la gestion, le conseil stratégique
et peut-être le plus important,
l'accès à de nouveaux contacts, à des réseaux et à de nouveaux marchés.
Donc, au niveau micro, il y a un rôle à jouer de ce mélange
d'investissement et de philanthropie.
Et au niveau macro, quelques intervenants ont conclu que
même la santé devrait être privatisée.
Mais ayant eu un père malade du coeur,
et réalisant que ce que notre famille pouvait payer
n'était pas ce qu'il aurait dû avoir,
et ayant un ami proche qui est intervenu pour aider,
je crois profondément que tout le monde mérite l'accès à la santé
à des prix accessibles.
Je pense que le marché peut nous aider à y arriver,
mais il faut une composante caritative
ou nous ne créerons pas, je pense, le genre de sociétés où nous voulons vivre.
Et ce sont vraiment ces leçons qui m'ont décidée à
fonder Acumen Fund il y a environ six ans.
C'est un fonds de capital-risque sans but lucratif pour les pauvres,
plusieurs oxymores dans la même phrase.
Il lève principalement des fonds caritatifs auprès d'individus, de fondations et de sociétés,
puis nous investissons des capitaux propres et de l'argent emprunté
dans des entités à but lucratif ou non
qui procurent médecine, logement, énergie, eau propre, à des prix abordables
pour des gens à faibles revenus en Asie du Sud et en Afrique,
afin qu'ils puissent faire leurs propres choix.
Nous avons investi environ 20 millions de dollars dans 20 entreprises différentes,
et ce faisant, créé environ 20.000 emplois,
et procuré des dizaines de millions de services à des gens
qui autrement n'auraient pas eu les moyens de les payer.
Je veux vous raconter deux histoires. Les deux se passent en Afrique.
Les deux parlent d'investissement dans des entrepreneurs
qui se consacrent au service, et connaissent bien les marchés.
Tous les deux sont au confluent de la santé publique et de l'entreprise,
et tous les deux, parce qu'ils sont des fabricants,
créent des emplois directement, et des revenus indirectement,
parce qu'ils sont dans le domaine du paludisme,
et que l'Afrique perd environ 13 milliards de dollars par an à cause du paludisme.
Et une meilleure santé entraîne de meilleurs revenus.
La première s'appelle Advanced Bio-Extracts Limited.
C'est une société fondée au Kenya il y a environ sept ans
par un entrepreneur incroyable qui s'appelle Patrick Henfrey, et ses trois collègues.
Ce sont des fermiers très expérimentés
qui ont connu tous les hauts et les bas de l'agriculture
au Kenya au cours des 30 dernières années.
Cette plante, c'est de l'armoise,
c'est le composant de base de l'artémisine,
qui est l'un des traitements les plus connus du paludisme.
C'est originaire de Chine et d'Extrême-Orient,
mais la plus forte prévalence du paludisme étant en Afrique,
Patrick et ses collègues ont dit "Introduisons-la ici,
parce que c'est un produit à fort potentiel commercial".
Les fermiers ont trois à quatre fois les rendements qu'ils auraient avec du maïs.
Donc en utilisant le capital patient, de l'argent qu'ils ont pu trouver très tôt,
dont le rendement est inférieur à celui du marché,
et qui allait les accompagner sur la durée et être conjugué
avec de l'aide à la gestion, de l'aide stratégique,
ils ont à présent créé une société qui achète auprès de 7.500 fermiers.
Ça touche donc environ 50.000 personnes.
Et je pense que certains d'entre vous ont visité --
ces fermiers sont aidés par KickStart et TechnoServe,
qui les aide à devenir plus auto-suffisants.
Ils l'achètent, ils la sèchent et l'apportent à cette usine
qui a été acquise en partie, là encore, par du capital patient de Novartis,
qui a un véritable intérêt à obtenir de la poudre
pour faire du Coartem.
Acumen a travaillé avec ABE depuis un an, un an et demi,
à la fois sur un nouveau business plan,
et sur les perspectives d'expansion, en les aidant pour la gestion,
pour faire les listes de conditions et lever des fonds.
Et j'ai vraiment compris ce que capital patient signifiait émotionnellement
au cours du dernier mois. Parce que la société était proprement
à 10 jours de prouver que leur produit
était au niveau de qualité requis pour faire du Coartem,
quand ils ont connu la plus grande crise de trésorerie de leur histoire.
Et nous avons appelé tous les investisseurs sociaux que nous connaissions.
Certains d'entre eux s'intéressent vraiment à l'Afrique
et comprennent l'importance de l'agriculture,
et ils ont même aidé les fermiers.
Et même en expliquant que si ABE disparaissait,
ces 7500 emplois disparaîtraient aussi,
nous arrivons parfois à la croisée des chemins entre le privé et le social.
Et il est temps de commencer à penser leur fusion possible de façon plus créative.
Donc Acumen a consenti non pas un mais deux prêts relais,
et la bonne nouvelle, c'est qu'ils ont atteint la qualité internationale et sont maintenant
pas loin de disposer de 20 millions de dollars pour passer à la prochaine étape,
et je crois que ce sera une des plus importantes sociétés d'Afrique de l'est.
Voici Samuel. C'est un fermier.
Il vivait dans les bidonvilles de Kibera
quand son père l'a appelé pour lui parler de l'armoise et de son potentiel commercial.
Alors il est revenu à la ferme, et en bref,
ils en ont à présent sept acres [3,5 hectares] cultivés.
Les enfants de Samuel sont à l'école privée,
et il commence à aider d'autres fermiers de la région à produire de l'armoise --
la dignité étant plus importante que la richesse.
L'histoire suivante, beaucoup d'entre vous la connaissent.
J'en ai un peu parlé à Oxford il y a deux ans,
et certains d'entre vous ont visité A to Z Manufacturing,
qui est l'une des grandes sociétés d'Afrique de l'Est.
Celle-là aussi est au confluent de la santé et de l'entreprise.
Et c'est vraiment une histoire de solution publique/privée
qui a bien marché.
Ça a commencé au Japon. Sumitomo a développé une technologie
pour imprégner une fibre à base de polyéthylène avec de l'insecticide bio,
dont on peut faire une moustiquaire
contre le paludisme, qui dure cinq ans sans avoir besoin de l'imprégner à nouveau.
Elle pourrait changer le vecteur de la maladie, mais comme l'armoise,
elle était produite seulement en Asie orientale, et dans une attitude socialement responsable
Sumitomo s'est dit "Pourquoi n'essaierions-nous pas
de la produire en Afrique, pour les Africains?"
L'UNICEF s'est présentée et a dit "Nous achèterons la plupart des moustiquaires
et nous les donnerons, selon l'engagement du Fonds Mondial
et des Nations Unies envers les femmes enceintes et les enfants, gratuitement".
Acumen est intervenu avec le capital patient,
et nous avons aussi aidé à identifier l'entrepreneur
avec lequel tous s'associer ici, en Afrique,
et Exxon a fourni la résine.
Et en passant en revue les entrepreneurs,
nous ne pouvions en trouver de meilleur qu'Anuj Shah,
de la société A to Z Manufacturing.
C'est une société qui existe depuis quarante ans, qui s'y connaît en fabrication.
Elle est passée de la Tanzanie socialiste à la Tanzanie capitaliste,
en continuant à prospérer. Elle avait environ 1000 employés quand nous l'avons connue.
Donc, Anuj a pris le risque entrepreneurial, ici en Afrique,
de produire un bien public acheté par l'institution humanitaire
pour s'occuper du paludisme.
Et, en bref encore, ils ont très bien réussi.
Dans la première année, la première moustiquaire est sortie en octobre 2003 --
Nous pensions qu'ils atteindraient directement 150.000 moustiquaires par an.
Ils en produisent maintenant huit millions par an,
et ils emploient 5000 personnes, dont 90 pour cent de femmes, non qualifiées pour la plupart.
Ils sont en joint-venture avec Sumitomo.
Donc, du point de vue d'une entreprise pour l'Afrique,
et du point de vue de la santé publique, ce sont de vrais succès.
Mas ce n'est qu'un début, si nous cherchons à résoudre les problèmes de pauvreté,
parce que ce n'est pas viable à long terme.
C'est une société avec un seul gros client.
Et si la grippe aviaire frappe, ou que pour une autre raison
le monde décide que le paludisme n'est plus une telle priorité, tout le monde perd.
Donc, Anuj et Acumen
ont parlé d'essayer le secteur privé,
parce que l'hypothèse de l'institution humanitaire, c'est que,
voyons, dans un pays comme la Tanzanie,
80 pour cent de la population gagne moins de deux dollars par jour.
Le prix de sortie d'usine est de six dollars,
et ça coûte encore six dollars à l'institution pour le distribuer,
donc le prix sur le marché serait environ de 12 dollars par moustiquaire.
La plupart des gens ne peuvent pas le payer, donc donnons-le.
Et nous disons "Et bien il y a une autre option.
Utilisons le marché comme la meilleure source d'information que nous ayons, et
voyons quel prix les gens paieraient pour ça, afin qu'ils puissent choisir en toute dignité.
Nous pouvons mettre en place une distribution locale,
et en fait, ça peut coûter beaucoup moins au secteur public".
Et nous sommes entrés dans une deuxième phase de capital patient avec A to Z,
avec un prêt mais aussi une subvention, afin que A to Z puisse jouer sur le prix
et écouter le marché, et nous avons découvert plusieurs choses.
Notamment qu'on peut trouver des prix différents,
mais que l'écrasante majorité se manifeste à un dollar par moustiquaire
et prend la décision d'acheter.
Et quand vous les écoutez, ils ont beaucoup à dire
sur ce qu'ils aiment et n'aiment pas,
et que certains circuits dont nous pensions qu'ils marcheraient n'ont pas marché.
Mais par l'expérimentation et l'itération permises
grâce au capital patient,
nous avons découvert que cela coûte environ un dollar dans le secteur privé
pour distribuer la moustiquaire, et un dollar pour l'acheter.
Donc d'un point de vue politique, quand vous commencez par le marché,
nous avons le choix.
Nous pouvons poursuivre à 12 dollars la moustiquaire, et le client ne paie rien,
ou nous pouvons au moins tenter pour part de faire payer un dollar la moustiquaire,
ce qui coûte six autres dollars la moustiquaire au secteur public,
donner aux gens la dignité de choisir, et avoir un système de distribution
qui pourrait, avec le temps, se pérenniser.
Il faut que nous commencions à avoir de telles conversations,
et je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de meilleur point de départ que le marché,
mais aussi que nous réunissions d'autre gens sur ce sujet.
Chaque fois que je rends visite à A to Z, je pense à ma grand-mère, Stella.
Elle ressemblait beaucoup à ces femmes derrière leurs machines à coudre.
Elle a grandi dans une ferme en Autriche, très pauvre,
n'avait pas tellement d'instruction.
Elle est partie aux Etats-Unis où elle a rencontré mon grand-père
qui était transporteur de ciment,
et ils ont eu neuf enfants. Trois sont morts en bas âge.
Ma grand-mère avait la tuberculose, et travaillait dans une boutique de machines à coudre
en faisant des chemises pour 10 cents de l'heure environ.
Comme tant de femmes que je vois à A to Z, elle
a travaillé dur chaque jour, a compris ce souffrir veut dire,
avait une foi profonde en Dieu, a aimé ses enfants
et n'aurait jamais accepté un don.
Mais parce qu'elle a eu la possibilité d'être sur le marché,
et parce qu'elle vivait dans une société donnant la sécurité
d'un accès abordable à la santé et à l'éducation,
ses enfants et les enfants de ceux-ci ont pu vivre
avec un vrai but et cherche à réaliser de vrais rêves.
Je regarde mes frères et soeurs, et mes cousins -- et comme j'ai dit,
nous sommes nombreux --
et je vois des professeurs et des musiciens, des gérants de fonds de couverture, des designers,
une soeur qui permet aux autres de réaliser leurs souhaits.
Et mon souhait, quand je vois ces femmes, quand je rencontre ces fermiers,
et que je pense à tous les gens de ce continent
qui travaillent dur chaque jour,
c'est qu'ils aient ce sentiment d'opportunité et de possibilité,
et qu'ils puissent aussi croire et avoir accès à des services
afin que leurs enfants eux aussi puissent vivre avec de grands buts.
Ça ne devrait pas être si difficile.
Mais cela requiert de notre part à tous un engagement
à refuser les hypothèses banales,
à sortir de nos cloisonnements idéologiques.
Cela suppose d'investir dans ces entrepreneurs engagés
dans le service aussi bien que dans le succès.
Cela suppose d'ouvrir vos deux bras en grand,
et d'attendre très peu d'amour en retour,
mais d'exiger de la responsabilité,
et mettre aussi sur la table la responsabilité.
Et plus que tout, plus que tout,
cela suppose que nous ayons tous le courage et la patience,
que nous soyons riches ou pauvres, Africains ou non,
du coin ou de la diaspora, de gauche ou de droite,
de commencer vraiment à s'écouter les uns les autres.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)